a little bit more on kyle freeland after
the
injury prevented an early start this
will be his 13th appearance of the year
and it's billy was telling you about
forget the wins and losses he's one and
six but the last seven he's been lights
out
one-two pitch swing and a miss got him
with a breaking ball
freeland opens the night with a
strikeout
and a crisp strikeout at that
freeland from the third base corner of
the rubbers pitch swing and a foul tip
held on to by elias diaz
a pair of strikeouts for kyle
well i guess you can't have a better
start than
kyle freeland did in the top of the
first
ortega contreras boating all strikeout
victims starting pitcher for the cubs mr
zach davies brought to you by budweiser
this buds for you he'll sink it good
change up occasional curveball
occasional cutter all adds up six and
seven and a 4.39
era
grounded to short andrew romine gets the
start defensively there tonight one down
this is brendan rogers
wisdom who had been manning first in
washington over the weekend now at the
hot corner
coming over
in the udarvish trade for the cubs the
shift is on
well placed well played both sides go
three up and three down
and that is
down so yeah you can hear the screaming
the eruption coming from the cubs dugout
and
armor is going after somebody
that's david ross
and now
i think david ross has already been
thrown out of the game and they've got
they've got issue i know they've had
issues before
and
the games just started in hamry's
not very impressively thrown the manager
out of the game and only a couple
hitters so i don't think the league
looks too well at that
ross now out talking
jaw to jaw with hammery david doing all
the talking hamri doing the listening
and uh david walks away and he'll watch
the rest of the game from the cubs
clubhouse
pine for these opportunities
and well struck by
schwendel down the line hap headed for
third harris will hold him up there and
in his first start for the cubs
schwendel delivers the extra base hit
and a couple in scoring position
jason drove in a run over the weekend in
washington
on the ground to first handled by crone
he'll step on the bag two down but half
will come in to score trevor three for
14 with a home run in his career
matchups with davies
28 year old from gilbert arizona
oh this ball tag left center field this
will take one hop and kicks off the wall
it'll be a lead off double for story
corey that came off the bat hot it did
that was as connected as i've seen
trevor in a long time i think he uh
he found the timing on zach davies right
there and just absolutely put it
together and that will load the bases
with no one out
for the very war elias diaz
looks like he's hitting a homer at night
[Applause]
has his last six weeks been incredible
or what
it has been uh you mentioned feels like
every day
the thing about elias
this man is
super strong 4-1 in the fourth inning
nobody on two down for ian happ
here's a deep drive to left off the bat
of ian happ in the corner if it's fair
it's gonna be a long home run that ball
is going to be
a home run for ian happ he clobbered one
right down the line and left the only
question was fair or foul
it was fair and it's a home run for ian
his 11th of the year
and now it's a four to two ball game
so first and third nobody out now for
sam hilliard
hilliard drives it high and deep right
field take a good look you won't see it
for long
three run jack sam hilliard
that looked like a two iron for sam
hilliard that's now his sixth home run
and
the swing path since he's returned from
aaa
is in such a good place
andrew robert
he still thinks he can make a play
romite beats it
for an infield single and now it's kyle
okay
he took
he took a pretty good shot adrenaline is
a beautiful thing right because watch
him run after the ball everything looks
fine he went down the stairs up into the
clubhouse he was followed by the two
trainers bud black and steve foster
they came back after some deliberation
and they decided yes
uh he would go back out obviously he
went back out to throw his warm-up
pitches and uh i'm guessing he didn't
feel very comfortable he's not real
happy either and unfortunately the
rockies are gonna have to make a
pitching change
sam air mailed a ball into the rockies
bullpen last time up a three-run homer
this is gonna be a hit for hilliard diaz
is gonna get a green light and haps
throw a good a second you're not going
to get hilliard it's going to go as if
one scores dumbo for sale
and the rockies now leading eight to two
rimel tapia
now back up the middle base hit
hilliard around third he'll score easily
rival tapia with his 44th rbi makes it
9-2
see what cj can do he's in a couple of
grand slams already this year
there's a base hit the center field
that'll bring two home
as tapia follows dazza
cj crow
rbi is
44-45 for crow and the round is on
here comes the 1-1
point foreign lines one toward right
that's a base hit
ortega rounding third he's going to
score opposite field run scoring single
for wilson contreras and now it's an 11
to three ball game
trying to
get something cooking and that is the
head of sam hilliard
contreras to third and he'll head for
home
david bodie with the
rbi double and a couple runs in the
inning
[Music]
roger scores another double for story
that's the swing
crow drives his deep to left and it is
off the wall
story will jog home
and cj hit it so hard it's a 350 foot
single
that won't get through
jason racing for second
as hat heads for home and another run
batted in for hayward
got hayward at third
please call the bog yes he did
he's waving hayward home the part of
santos with a cheap run for the cubs
that's a broken back flare hampson will
get out he'll make the catch and that'll
end the ball game
a wonderful return to coors field for
the rockies